[Music]
my name is Scott Ellis i'm a product
manager here at google working on
privacy security related technology and
we're to talk a little bit about that
today and just to start who here is
anybody here attend today's keynote this
morning so so we're going to talk about
some of the stuff that we said that was
announced there today now this is a
picture I took from the back of the room
we talked a little bit about sensitive
data in different tools that we have to
handle it to manage it and process that
data and so we'll talk about that today
but you know first you know what I want
to cover here is really you know talking
about kind of data and collaboration in
the modern era what we're doing today
some of the trends were saying and
specifically talk about some of the
tools that we have on our cloud platform
in G sweet and on cloud end on our
production gcp platform and then give a
little bit of background on sensitive
data on personal identifiable
information and then the heart of the
talk is really to welcome some our
friends here from the University of
Chicago to talk a little bit deeper
about data science the identification
and some of the challenges as they face
in some of the opportunities that they
see so just a few trends when we look at
data now what these are things I picked
out that I think are really kind of
driving a lot of what we're doing so
first we have a lot more real-time
interaction with our users with
customers and with devices so this is
again data coming in streaming in a lot
of back-and-forth interactions users
it's very fast very data-driven and this
is creating a lot of larger richer data
sets and I use the word richer because
we all see these large data sets and we
think that we can extract out
information from them value like just
valuable information learn more about
how our customers or users are
interacting predict things that they
might do and in some cases even you can
come up with life-saving predictions and
life-saving things that we can learn
from that and as part of that is it's
real time and we're getting larger and
larger data sets we also want to make
faster decisions so we want to be able
to look at this data and we want to be
able to act on it very quickly we don't
want to take
to figure out what we should have done
if we need to interact with somebody in
seconds or minutes so we need to be both
dealing with larger data sets and making
faster decisions and we talked about
collaboration that just means we need
streamlined collaboration we need to be
able to talk to each other back and
forth in real time or near real time we
need to be able to just add somebody in
to a document or share something with
them and have it just be a seamless
experience and again some of that data
that we're talking about is sensitive so
it's not all just you know bits some of
this stuff is very sensitive information
specifically sensitive information about
people that we do need to protect so
securing this data is crucial we spent a
lot of time looking at you know across
the board of how we secure data things
like two factor authentication setting
the right access control audit logging
for when people go in and access data
reviewing those audits who generating
logs and auditing them encrypting data
and a whole bunch of other things that
we do and in fact we spend a lot of time
you know a lot of effort in securing
data to mitigate risk but sometimes at
some point you actually want to do
something with your data you want to
open it up and the last pocket if any of
you saw that with Joe did sort of you
want to use a key you might actually
open the vault and let people in and do
something with your data that's kind of
the idea here and once you do that the
data itself can be a risk so once you do
something you need to kind of be aware
of who you're sharing it with what
you're doing and in some cases take
action to reduce that risk of the actual
in the actual data so let's go through
an example with sheets so Google sheets
of the very its spreadsheet app on G
sweet this is built in a lot of it was
built from the ground up with a lot of
collaboration in mind so here's just an
example I've got a sheet here you can
see a column we're talking about
customer satisfaction one of these
customers has low satisfaction and i'm
looking here and i want to know why so i
want to ping in jannat who is a vendor
that we work with from another company
and ask them to go in and figure out why
is this customer not satisfied why is
there customer satisfaction low maybe
they want to contact and figure this out
so I just simply go in here I plus them
in put a plus sign put their name ask
them a question click go very simple
very easy this solves that streamline
case it's very easy to get here and do
this but let's zoom out a little bit so
we have fast easy collaboration but
let's zoom out we didn't notice is that
in column F we had an open note comment
field that was stuck in here and in one
of these comments somebody decided to
write some sensitive information so this
was not my intent to share this I was
trying to focus on this other column
attacked another another row but as soon
as I share this with Janet she's going
to see the whole spreadsheet so how
would we mitigate something like this in
kind of a corporate app well go through
an example of what we have so in G sweet
we offer something called data loss
prevention where you can set very simple
policies around this and those policies
really good gear around three main
things triggers conditions and actions
so in this case we look at something
like a trigger I'm going to share this
data you know what with somebody outside
of my domain the condition is I want to
look for some sensitive information in
this case we're going to look for Social
Security numbers driver's license
numbers and credit card numbers another
one take some action so in this case I'd
probably want to block sharing may be
notifying admin things like that so if
we go back to that and as soon as I
click comment here what's actually
happening in the background is sheets
will look at this and say I need to go
ad Janet to the stock she needs
permissions to view it I need to send
her an email to go click and view it but
with vop we will first check to see if
there's an issue with that kind of
action and prove provide some sort of
warning or block the actual sharing in
this case document contains a social
security number and so we can't share it
externally and that's pretty
straightforward a DLP helps
organizations manage their data and it
can help meet legal regulatory
compliance contractual obligations and
it's a pretty standard operating feature
but what about production and
development environments this is an
issue that at Google we face a lot we
have we use G sweet we love it but we
have a huge production environment and
it we seamlessly go back and forth with
one to the other in a lot of cases and
so for us we were very concerned about
what about when you're developing an app
what about when you're dealing with
large scale data that we call kind of
like production data data about it's
coming out of our systems about of our
out of our applications about of our
kind of out of our day-to-day business
and so this morning we talked about a
new offering that we have called the
data loss prevention API what this
really is is we're taking a lot of that
functionality that you get to in G sweet
going through a policy and a rules
engine and providing that capability as
an API directly into into into the cloud
platform and the idea here is that you
can now build this into your own apps
you can take the same kind of logic that
we built into gmail and drive and sheets
and build it into your own applications
or workflows and I'll show a few
examples here so again it's the same
engine you know that we've we've build
gmail and drive on and giving your
capabilities like to be able to classify
your data redaction sitive data
efficiently manage sensitive data so
again you may just not even know what
you have you have a lot of information
coming in you've got different assets
and you just want to classify them and
manage them appropriately and one of the
things that we think this really does is
unlocks more of the cloud there's things
that you're not doing today that you
could be doing but and by having a
little bit more insight on your data we
think that it can open up more of the
cloud so let's go is an example so we
showed something in the keynote this
morning we showed a live demo app of
sort of a customer support chat so going
to kind of walk through that use case
here so imagine you have this customer
support app and in there you have a chat
transcript and use chat in this case
you've had a customer interaction and
it's a very end maybe you want to email
a copy of that to the customer so you
have a simple action in your app you
click email email copy to customer but
in this case we've detected that they're
sensitive information in there and you
may want to prompt the user again in a
custom-built app the same kind of way
that we prompt is someone in sheets so
in this case we've warned them that
there is a credit card number a social
security number a phone number and so
maybe you don't want email this to a
customer that doesn't kind of show a
very good best practice so yeah your
option could be just don't do it or
maybe you want to go in and redact that
stuff out the customer still gets the
meaning behind the transcript but you're
not revealing their credit card number
to their AOL account or wherever it's
going
and another example but now let's say
you have that chat transcript you've
probably got millions of these and so
you take that one chat transcript you
export all of them and you want to do
something with it you want to maybe
loaded up to a bigger analytics machine
learning natural language processing you
kind of want to analyze what kind of
trends do I see in my free tax customer
support chat so to do that first you
might want to reduct it so again similar
concept go in strip out everything
that's in there and then send it into
something like analytics for machine
learning so again this is just a safer
way kind of unlock more usage in the
cloud and so the idea here again is
you've got your raw data sitting
somewhere in a production environment
maybe it's just sitting on GCS maybe
it's loaded up in a big query maybe it's
just hidden in some asset you have
access to and you need to extract it out
and you want to get it over here in to
do you know higher level analytics
machine learning maybe just app
development so think about wanting to
have test data you want to you want to
run through the UI and see what it would
look like you maybe have debug logs that
are coming out you want to analyze those
in a development environment things like
that or you want to improve how you
share this data so you're already doing
sign of secure sharing with data where
you lock down the apples and make sure
the right people have access but again
maybe they don't need to see everything
maybe the people doing analysis only
need to see the bulk content and not the
sensitive bits and that's where again
using an API like ours you look at look
for the sensitive data go and redact it
and then again enable those same use
cases so try it out so you can go to
this site to find out more about this
this API we also have a demo demo on it
that you can go in and start typing on
here and just type stuff in play around
with it see what is the text as you type
you'll see things kind of filter in at
the bottom in this case I just give it a
couple sample things and you see if the
bottom it starts to come out with hey
here's what we found we're kind of
confident we have a certain like likely
heard of confidence level here and you
start to get an idea of what you might
see in the API as well Kings like
offsets where this data is found things
like that and I'm going to go through
and show you an actual demo here you
just get out of here and this is just a
very very simple demo we built a demo on
App Engine going in and calling this API
so in this case what we've done is built
a simple feedback web web page so here a
customer could go in type something I'm
going to go ahead and let's see here and
just type in please Dave my credit card
and this is a valid card it's a test
published test card and it's important
that it's valid a couple reasons I'll go
over some one to submit that thank you
for submitting it and then we're going
to go into an admin view here and we're
just going to see an admin view so this
might be something again customer went
in submitted something maybe they
shouldn't have put in a feedback form if
your default admin view would be let's
just show the information but redact out
the sensitive information here and so
what we've built here is too simple
views calling in the API in this case we
decided to store the actual raw data but
not display it to the to the user by
default so what we see here is just a
bunch of Asterix replaced any time we
saw VII now if a user if an admin needs
to see that that can be a role-based
choice we have a button here that says
show PII where you can click it and
you'll start to see the actual
underlying TI that's in there and again
that's just what we decided to do on
this app you might want to generate
extra audit logging for somebody who
does reveal that or just restrict it
completely to certain people that can
handle that level of detail but just a
very simple app to show the point here
and let's see let's get back and that's
um just walk through what we did so
again we took something were you a very
simple feedback order form we sent
information n we showed how you can
basically build a view where that
information is redacted live shown to
the user with with asterisks in this
case and give them the ability to click
and show the actual VII and now I'm
going to show you a little bit of what
that looks like using a REST API call so
in the back end this is this is what a
simple call would look like and it's in
a JSON format so for developers you'll
be able to understand this but even if
you can't you can almost read this like
just human-like text right I have an
here it's got a value and you can see
this might be what a customer might send
in his feedback my order did not go
through and then we want to look for
certain things here so this is similar
to that policy we saw out in sheets I
want to look for credit card social
security cards and email addresses click
send and you'll get a response like this
so in this case we look for three things
but we only found one of them and we
give a lot of detail here so we've said
include the quote show what kind of
likelihood we have and tell me where you
found it in a string of text it's a
simple offset so that's how simple it is
just even using restful api calls just
to send data and send it out we also
have options to do redaction we also
support images you can do restful calls
just basically kind of encoding the in
the basics before the image and send it
in it's that simple and so how this
might be used so we kind of now zoomed
out on this app that we build and we
said okay so we have an app built on App
Engine does maybe some some you know
front-end that we have here and this is
the feedback part of it so what we
showed today was basically taking this
API and building it in at the app level
where you can do classification and
reduction in line in the app make it a
functional part of your application but
you could also in the backend do it
under you know when you're working with
your data in this case we looked at
building it into a cloud dataflow
pipeline before it gets into bigquery we
wanted to go in and batch and massive
like remove the PII before we hit
bigquery but you could also use this as
a tool to just understand your data and
then set i am roles appropriately so you
maybe just have a dynamic thing that's
scanning every week every month every
day and as soon as you see something
that is classified as let's say having
certain sensitive data you lock it down
with an IM role we're only certain
people that are qualified can see that
so there's a lot of ways that you can
read this in into your workflow so now
i'm going to go a little bit and give a
little bit of background on sensitive
data mpi i and and then we'll welcome
our friends up on stage as well and so
what we've covered today is we've talked
a lot about finding sensitive data
specifically identifiable data or which
is often called personally identifiable
information PII you'll send
and see the word SPI I for sensitive
personally identifiable information
you'll see the word pH I which for
people in the health will know exactly
what that means protected health
information I've been in a lot of rooms
where people think it means personal
health information or something like
that but really what it is is its
information protected under HIPAA and it
kind of breaks into two parts and the
last clock really covered this but it
has to be protected under HIPAA you have
to be coming from a covered entity but
it also means that its data that is
identifiable and so it does have some
overlap with just identifiers in
personal identifiable information so
some of these are pretty obvious if you
look at this names such security numbers
passport numbers telephone numbers
various things that you can find with
our API and it also talks about some
things that are trickier to find and
we're going to go in a little bit of
background about what those are and
other things that you can do to kind of
handle that but one is highlighted here
in blue is a persisting static
identifier something that is not well
defined but maybe is kind of identifies
a small group or a single individual now
let's go kind of take a look at what
classification looks like or what are
the things that we do when we're
classifying this data so we'll go with a
very simple example again this is my
credit card followed by a string of
digits so what we look at here is a
bunch of clues we can look at things
like structure you know this looks like
a credit card it has dashes between
every four digits we also have some
algorithms that can go and actually
check this number and it's called a
checksum in the case of credit cards
where it looks at the number itself and
validates that it's real so if you put
just 16 digit numbers with dashes that
doesn't mean it's a credit card in this
case we can check that it is a real
credit card or at least passes the test
for one we also can look at context
clues in this case it's pretty clear
that this is a credit card just contact
saying it just format saying it and
there's some math effectively analyzing
this and saying it and so what do we do
with that so we showed today wait it one
way is to just simply redact it out
other things you can do is once you know
where it is you can go in and do things
like hashing or tokenization so in this
case we're showing just sort of a random
hash we purposely made one that doesn't
look very pretty
because but that's fine it's a hash the
idea being that every time I see a
certain credit card maybe I want to
generate the same hash that opens up a
lot of opportunities for for kind of
trend analysis and analytics but you can
also do things like format preserving
encryption and format preserving tokens
so in this case I've generated something
that kind of looks and acts like a
credit card but it isn't it's a token
that represents the credit card this is
important if you were really strict on
the format that you have if you're using
it in a UI where you want to display
something and you want the end user to
kind of see it as it would be we're
displaying the middle one would look
kind of boss it might look like a bug to
them so there's a lot of techniques for
obfuscating this kind of data first step
is go find it but there's some
challenges there so we're going to talk
about one of the challenges here is
names so here's a very simple example
and I'm looking at a case where the
stuff in green you've green boxes around
the stuff we found we classified and we
missed something here so we missed the
last name of Zhang so if we were to use
a redaction in this very straightforward
take all the stuff we found and put X's
there that works except what we've
actually done is very obviously
highlighted this thing we missed so
anyone looking at this it sees X's
anytime they see a name knows we found
it knows we're adapted it so when you
see a random name in there that a human
can pick out they kind of know you
missed it probably means it's the real
thing so there's other options here so
Miss talked a little bit about this and
it's a common thing of basically hiding
in plain sight but it's the idea of
using surrogate replacements or
realistic surrogate replacements so
instead of X's we use other names so you
could go in here for example take the
same example and now we're going to
replace Janet with Cindy and we replace
Smith's with Roberts and we're going to
leave this thing we missed because again
we didn't catch it so we can't change it
and now in the final output we still
missed Zhang but it's harder to find out
it's harder to see that we missed it
again it's not foolproof there are
attacks you can look at this but it's
things like this that you can do to
reduce the risk of somebody looking at
this and obviously finding the
information that you didn't want them to
find so this is an example of hiding in
plain sight and again pointing it out
here this is kind of like tokenizing we
showed us a credit card but we really
doing is you were using a realistic name
as a replacement there and we've done it
in this case with integrity where Janet
is replaced with Cindy in all cases a
very simple example here but if you did
want to know that this is the same name
you can do that and now we'll just look
at one last concept here it kind of
touches on that persist ecstatic
persistent static identifier and it's
the concept of kin annuity and I'll do a
very rough example of this but imagine
you stripped out all of the sensitive
information that you think is in your
data set you stripped out credit cards
social security cards maybe even names
you've got it really down but what you
have is you have a data set with some
sensitive information let's just say
it's salary information or something
about about employees in this case let's
say it's Googlers and you wanted to do
some analysis on job title so what you
want to do is keep their job title in
look at maybe salaries and promotions
and things that could be sensitive and
use some analysis on it well in this
case seems pretty straightforward the
obvious problem here is something like
CEO of Google it's not hard for anyone
in this room to guess who that is today
it would be one person if you looked
over a 10-year period it's still down to
three people pretty much so that's an
outlier that's something that's we
wouldn't have thought of as a unique
identifier but it pretty much is
software engineer not so much but you
can imagine there's a whole spectrum
here so there's a whole spectrum of sort
of what we call these high-risk outliers
in our case at Google we have a lot of
different engineering titles there's
software engineer their senior software
engineer there's distinguished engineer
there's things like Google fellows all
of these things are different job titles
and some of them are relatively unique
relatively rare and which fall into a
high-risk outlier group so those are the
kind of things where you can do
distribution analysis and what kanan a
MIDI does is looks at how many people
kind of group into that particular
attribute so in a simple way software
engineer in this small example would
have a KF for four people in it just in
the sample and see you of google has AK
of one so if you were to think of a
threshold that you'd want to set again
this is a very small data size but you
want your threshold maybe to be two or
three in the small example but in a
larger data set you might be looking at
setting a threshold of 10 20 100
a thousand really depending on the use
case and how sensitive that information
is so this is again just one more kind
of a little bit more advanced concept
but an important one to consider when
you're looking at sensitive data so
we've covered here again is some tools
that we have to help you Angie sweet and
specifically taking some of those tools
and giving the power to you to weave
them into your own apps weave them into
your own workflow as your own pipelines
you can find out more about this again
online google cloud or cloud google com
flash dlp and now we'd like to do is
welcome to more friends up on stage
Michael and Sam from University of
Chicago to talk a little about more
about the challenges so I've covered
some of the basics but what we really
want to hear from is you know real data
scientists who face this challenge and
are doing you know want to do real
things with data and face this issue
with sensitive sensitive information and
data notification and so I'm going to
hand it off to them great let's go thank
you Scott so we're going to try and
share a little bit about how we look at
this as physicians as folks in the
healthcare sector and as people who use
large data sets to try and make
discovery and we're also going to try
and share some things where we feel like
there may be problems around around the
identification that we're hopeful we'll
get solved in the next in the next few
years and so we're going to start with
is yeah we're a couple of doctors who
are up here and I suspect several people
are wondering what conference we you
think we're at we actually think that
cloud storage and a identification are
important we think they're critical to
improving the pace of discovery in
healthcare and we're going to try and
convince you of that we're going to try
and convince you that it's important to
the kind of research that we do and at
the end of the next 15 minutes we think
you'll agree with that so I'm a doc I'm
an ICU doc I have some grants to study
things like this it is important for me
to say that I said on a couple of
committees that provide advice to the
federal government the things
I will talk about our my opinions not
theirs but I do want you to know that I
man I see you doc I'm a critical care
doc that influences how I think about
things it's especially most people have
never heard of we're the specialty that
cares for you if your risk of dying is
very high in the next 24 hours I'm the
chief quality officer of the University
of Chicago which is a moderate-sized
health system in the Midwest I work with
what for health care or reasonably sized
data sets and I've experienced both good
care and horrible care perpetrated on my
family and feel a need to try and make
that better so I'm Sam Belgian bomb I'm
at the university of chicago and i just
wanted to point out a few things about
the work that I do so I have received
and I do receive funding from the
government for some of the work that I
do and those grants are disclosed here
I'm also a co-founder of a company
called litmus health which is building
an analytics platform to collect mobile
data for clinical trials so that work
has given me an interesting perspective
into the into how commercial entities
have to think about privacy of data and
I'll try to bring some of that to the
talk today I have set on a few
government committees the ones that are
mostly relevant or things around
building data standards for things like
mobile mobile devices and for how we
collect data for clinical trials my day
job is that I'm trained as a pediatric
oncologist so I take care of kids with
cancer and blood diseases I spend most
of my time running the center for
research informatics at the University
of Chicago which is a 40-person group
providing informatics support to the
division my training is mostly in
medicine and molecular biology but I
took a detour to get a degree in
biomedical informatics and so that's how
my three worlds come together now and
what I really try to do is to figure out
how we can take data and how we can
democratize it so that people can use it
to study and improve health outcomes so
we're going to start with a question
we're to come back to this a little bit
later in the talk and the question is
just this
what is the difference between a heart
attack and a cardiac arrest it turns out
actually most people don't know this
ninety-five percent of people who have a
heart attack in the United States today
survive and cardiac arrest is the
recognition that you are dead and so in
it tastes somewhat more serious
condition and we're going to come back
to the question of wouldn't you like to
know it's coming so that you can prevent
it and we're going to try and show you
how we've used data to address that at
the University of Chicago we do want to
point out some things about healthcare
that may be different than other areas
that use data the first is what the
office looks like and so this is the
picture of an ICU that Google legal
would allow me to to take a look at but
if you look at this here you know there
are 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
continuous infusion IV pumps you can see
that this child is actually intubated on
life support on mechanical ventilation
their number of other monitors and
things there's a ten-thousand-dollar bed
there's two tubes invading the thoracic
cavity here to keep the lung open and oh
yeah there's a patient in the middle of
that what we don't talk about is that
each of these devices generate data the
data are not aggregated in a standard
way they're not stored in the standard
way they're not joined in a standard way
and all of this happens in an
environment that is chaotic and
difficult to influence even with the
world's fanciest algorithms our instant
messaging Q may also look different than
yours these devices which many of you
will recognize from history books are
wired directly into our adrenal glands
and they come across with these things
like hi dr. Howell can come see patients
so in so suctioning blood from the
airway in GI tract now on as much oxygen
as it's possible to give thanks Sarah
our residents and trainees are very
polite at the university of chicago or
hi dr. hal just took over care for this
patient in the ICU significant
respiratory distress anesthesia coming
to start life support think she would
benefit
from thrombectomy which means having her
chest cut open her pulmonary artery in
size and a clot taken out and so those
things are disruptive to workflow when
you're trying to plan your day but they
also represent a piece of absolutely
critical information that is stored and
analyzed nowhere so one of the things
that I'm hoping that you'll be convinced
of today is that the way we think about
privacy and health care is potentially
different than the way people that are
not in healthcare think about it the
things that we ask of our patients are
very very personal and you know michael
takes care of patients in the ICU i take
care of families with children with
cancer many of them go to the ICU and
the things we ask of our patients are
things we do at the worst times in their
lives you can imagine that that we're
asking them to discuss things about
deaths things about struggles are having
at home think about the things that
you'll discuss with your doctor without
thinking twice things about about
pregnancy about about psychiatric
illness it's incredible the kinds of
things will share with our healthcare
provider and we want to do that with the
assumption that those data are going to
remain private and that if our health
care data are shared they're done so
they're done so in a way that respects
that privacy I'm going to show a couple
examples of people that had really good
intentions about sharing data but that
when it when they when they published
their data they did so in a way that
actually exposed patient's medical
records and again and invaded their
privacy this is a landmark paper from
about 15 years ago from Latonya Sweeney
that actually focuses on k anonymity
like Scott was referring to and here are
two data sets that they were able to get
their hand the data set on the left it's
working the data set on the left is
medical data that was released with good
intentions whoever released this data
set felt that this was going to be data
that that that was was private that
wasn't going to give up anybody's
privacy they had things like their
diagnosis procedures they had and then
three seemingly innocuous items their
zip code their birthday and their gender
on the rice is a voter registration list
which neighbor
quested which was publicly available
that had a bunch of things seemingly
innocuous name address their party
affiliation but also had zip code
birthday and sex and I don't think it's
really difficult to see that if you were
to combine those two data sets you could
match on those three and what they were
able to do was to identify many of the
patients in this set including the
governor of Massachusetts at the time
whose data was here and so this again
these folks had good intentions that
publish these data but when you looked
into the sets they published they were
able to expose some of the privacy this
I think is a fascinating example so this
was a paper that was published showing
an influenza outbreak this is Boston and
each of the red dots is a site of an
influenza outbreak in Boston and what
the authors hope to do in the study was
be able to understand where the sites of
influenza worse that they could track
the outbreak and so they published this
in a paper and this research group at
Harvard took this took this set of data
and when I teach this I say how would
you solve this problem and almost always
somebody raises their hand and says I
would just put a Google map on top of it
and of course that's what this research
group did they overlaid a Google map on
top and very quickly they were able to
identify eighty percent of the eighty
percent of the dots on the map to the
exact address and when they relaxed the
radius they were able to identify a
hundred percent of the people in this
study so an incredible invasion of
privacy completely unintentionally
innocuous to put dots on a map and when
I teach about this that we talk about
things like how would you obscure the
data and students will say well you
would shift everything by ten feet in
some random direction and that would do
it and yes that would do it in the
middle of Boston but if you shift
everybody 10 feet in South Dakota you're
going to move somebody from their house
to their barn and then you will you
won't you won't protect anybody's
anonymity no offense to South Dakota so
but that's the point here is that it's
hard to do these problems you have to
know the population you're studying as
has been mentioned in other talks here
there are a lot of regulation around
sharing data the this is a simplified
version of the government's take on how
we have to protect data
and what I want to get across to you is
that there's a financial penalty here
which is not cheap it's fifty thousand
dollars per violation so if somebody
loses a spreadsheet with a bunch of
patients data it could run up in the
millions very quickly and we're talking
about data over hundreds of thousands of
patients but there's also the what we
used to call the above the fold risk
back when people read newspapers we had
this concept that when something was
really bad it would show up on the front
page and you would see it on the stack
of newspapers the current version of
that is the wall of shame that's
maintained by the Health and Human
Services which actually will publish
anybody that has a breach of over 500
patients so you will end up on here if
you have a breach and HHS now is
tweeting out whenever they post a new
breach and so you will get tagged and
their tweet and you can now find
yourself on the wall of shame if you if
you do this so the risk is actually very
high both from a financial perspective
as well as a reputational risk the HIPAA
is a set of rules that governs how we
share data it came out of the the
Recovery and Reinvestment Act and
they've defined 18 identifier of things
you have to remove to make it
de-identified and there's things you
would expect name address email address
and so forth and but just to make sure
that they got everything they added this
one at the end here called any other
unique identifying number so even and I
think the last talk mentioned something
about this too in the previous session
that it can be any it can be any sort of
something that could be used to identify
the person and so you have to really be
careful as you share data that if you
just strip out these things that are on
this page here that that might not be
enough and we'll come back to that
toward the end of the talk so one of the
things to think about in health care
data is that it's distributed everywhere
right and that's actually the dirty
secret that people don't talk about if
you think about all the places your
health care data are they're everywhere
this was highlighted during the election
when there was these calls to release
the full medical record for the
presidential candidates everybody wanted
to see the full record and they were
probably imagining some stack of papers
that was the full record but as you've
seen just in this short talk so far the
full record includes electronic health
record data even data that you're
finding on pagers data that you're
finding from pumps
it could be scattered everywhere and the
interesting quote from this article that
the author wrote he wrote her medical
records are in bits and pieces and
doctors offices filing cabinets hospital
records departments and hard to access
computers just like yours probably and I
would challenge anybody to to come up
with all the spots that their medical
record exists all the way down to the
the grammar school office where your
vaccination record is probably sitting
from from years ago so your data are
scattered everywhere so what do we do
about this we want to get the data into
a place where we can analyze it and we
can do this safely and with good
protection of privacy we need to fill up
a warehouse with data so at the
University of Chicago the way we've
approached this is is too we call it
getting our hands dirty with the data we
have a group that I run called the
Center for Research informatics the guys
that work for me a column data Wranglers
because because they get in there they
learn about the data they model the data
they make sure that we're understanding
what's coming through as we take data
from the hospital systems and we built
what we think is a very well organized
clean warehouse where when you want to
request data on a particular disease we
can get at the data in a way that you
have assurances about the quality of the
data you're getting and I think one of
the one of the exciting things about the
about collaborating working with Scott
and working with the Google team is that
is that we have a mutual expectation
about the quality of the data and the
quality of the analysis that's going to
come out of it so the the other piece to
think about with healthcare is that it
may be organized differently than you
think and the one study that I'll show
you today that someone else did is how
much r ND is done in the health care
delivery system when we think about the
health care system we think about
biotech and pharma and other areas but
in fact the healthcare delivery system
spends less than 1% of revenues on R&D
the food and beverage injuries industry
spends five fold more on RD than the
healthcare delivery system does today
and that is in some ways one of the
crippling problems of modern American
here is that we're not organized in that
way and so one of the things that we've
attempted to do and we'll show you how
this plays out in a little bit is
reorganized in a way where the folks
doing operations in health care and the
folks doing research don't live in
different places we call that our Center
for healthy delivery science and
innovation and it's one of the things
that lets us work on really interesting
collaborations that impact patients
today not 40 years in the future I am
going to return and try and give an
example of this in action because why do
we care about data we do care about you
know data helps us get more efficient it
helps us make margin it helps us reduce
waste but it also impacts real people in
the real world and we'll give you two
examples of how we've done that so we
said what's the difference between a
heart attack in a cardiac arrest
ninety-five percent of people with a
heart attack survive cardiac arrest is
the recognition that you are dead and
CPR doesn't work eighty percent of the
time unlike on TV and so the University
of Chicago has a long history of
excellence in cardiac arrest research
starting more than a decade ago and with
a team led by Matt sure Peck and Donna
Edelson has been doing predictive work
in how is it you would figure out who
would have a cardiac arrest or develop
critical illness before that happens in
the end they did a five Hospital study
with more than a quarter million
patients and you know I'm a predictive
model ER at heart this thing warms it
warms my heart it's a 27 dimensional
model it's got spline turns the whole
nine yards and if you like areas under
the curve as a way of assessing how
useful the model is this is today the
best predicted model for cardiac arrest
on the planet developed in our patients
but at the end of this you know what are
these researchers have they have a paper
published in a journal affecting no
patient anywhere and so we've been able
to take this weave an enterprise
services bus architecture at the
University of Chicago turn this live and
see over and
above our usual methods for responding
we've seen at twenty percent reduction
in cardiac arrest in about a year and a
half span after implementation of this
that's a pretty clever thing that we've
been able to do but it and it's gotten
some news about how we've taken things
from the data warehouse from the center
for research informatics turned it into
something in the real world but there's
another interesting question that now we
can attack and it's actually the
question of can critical illness be
contagious so imagine that you're
hospitalized and it's a 10-bed unit and
you're in the third bed or your mom's in
the third bed or your brother or your
daughter and what happens if the person
in bed sick gets sick and needs the ICU
or has a cardiac arrest what happens to
you is the risk contagious and so if you
thought for a minute about how you would
study that it's actually a really
difficult problem to sort out and so we
took about 90 thousand patients data
time ordered them broke them down into
time blocks ran the 27 dimensional
multivariable model sorted out a zillion
other factors we were able to answer the
question of this that in fact yeah if
that person has Crump's and goes to the
ICU for the next six hours your risk of
developing critical illness goes up by
eighteen percent after extremely careful
control for how sick you are and if two
people have that happen then the risk
goes up by fifty four percent and so now
we're attempting to turn that live in to
how do we actually deal with and adjust
with with that but these are examples of
the reasons that we care so much about
the quality of data how we get them how
we get the data sorted and then how we
begin to be able to use it but privacy
protection is critical to making
discoveries like this we can't do it
without it and it's really hard to do
privacy well while making discoveries
that still save lives if you are moving
outside your own institution and so we
said healthcare data may be a little bit
different privacy in healthcare maybe a
little bit different healthcare may not
have our in
these you would recognize it and that
privacy protection is critical to
discovery and so we are really excited
about the changes that have been
happening over the past few years we're
we're really good on our own at using
discrete data for predicting things
we've been doing that for a while it's
not easy but we've been sorting out how
to do it but today we're beginning to be
able to think about how we use the whole
electronic health record including the
notes that doctors and nurses and others
right and one of the problems is if
you're trained like I am as an
epidemiologist and healthcare researcher
once you get to 400 500 600 variables my
models don't work but if we start using
free text notes they're really new
challenges that are hard okay so hang in
there now I'm going to take you through
a couple examples of some of the
challenges of using free text notes and
I think they're going to highlight what
we're so excited about when it comes to
collaborating with Google on trying to
think about how to do the identification
of free text notes and how to do this
analysis over large sets of patient data
this is an example of a couple notes on
a patient's the note says who mr. Smith
is a 65 year old man with weight loss
submitted on august first mr. Smith
lives with his sister Jane and there's a
family history that Jane had
tuberculosis diagnosed in February so
you know if you're seeing this guy he's
got this weird unexplained weight loss
and he's living with somebody with
tuberculosis you immediately start
thinking could there be a connection
well if we try to de-identify this
information using standard redaction
will take out the names and the exact
dates and we're basically left with
blank is a 65 year old man with weight
loss admitted sometime last year blanks
lives with his sister blank and blank
had tuberculosis diagnosed sometime
useless right like that doesn't tell us
anything well we can do a little bit
smarter than that and we can actually
instead take the notes and we can take
out the name but we can preserve the
admit dates so we can say that so until
is a 65 year old man admitted with
weight loss on some dates and now we can
use the colors to say well so-and-so
lives with his sister another person and
then
other person had tuberculosis and
there's a relationship there so this
removes the hip identifier and it
satisfies the D identification but still
the computer's not telling us which is
painfully obvious to everybody's looking
at this is yeah something good something
else could be going on but I really
think that you should think about he
might have got TV from his sister so
this is an example of it relatively
simple heuristic for a human to come up
with but a difficult text problem for a
computer to solve if you want to
maintain privacy so why is the
identification and healthcare a hard
problem well it's hard for several
reasons one is that we're trained to
think that we need to connect the data
with the outcomes and for discrete data
that can be relatively easy but with
free text it can be much more difficult
to know what the data are the discrete
data that's in the text and what the
outcomes are we must remove the hit by
identifiers including the dates and in
practice when we do this with discrete
data like blood pressure and heart rate
it's easy to remove any of the hip
identifiers but as we move into free
text it becomes very difficult and you
need a high-performance environment to
do this when we were first thinking
about doing this collaboration we
thought how long would it take us to
de-identify our 20 million text notes
and the first feedback I got from my
team that even on our high performance
environment it would take us six months
to do it so I have a relatively complex
example to take us on out but I think
it's important and try to hang in here
in there with me because I think this is
very illustrative of the opportunity
here so here's Frank Jones is an 85 year
old man here for his annual checkup he's
been doing well but recently was forced
to move from his home in Batavia
Illinois to Elgin due to insufficient
funds his eldest son Craig was recently
killed in an automobile accident mr.
Jones remaining seven children all live
in illinois mr. Jones orthopedic surgeon
dr. Reeves has been concerned about his
leg following his amputation last year
for diabetes but overall he reports new
metal no new medical issues ok so
there's a lot of identifiers there so
let's just read act out the identifiers
that his name and you're left with this
note that takes out all the names and
there aren't any dates in here right and
there aren't any addresses and there's
no full zip code so this note by all
accounts
purposes would look to be de-identified
right but if you think back to the k
anonymity lecture we had before from
Scott there's something wrong with this
note because I would argue that it's not
been de-identified appropriately so what
identifier is remain in this note well I
would argue that being an 85 year old
man in a small town in Illinois is not a
very anonymous thing the fact that his
son was killed in a car accident the
fact that he was amputated amputee the
fact that he has eight children now
seven children i would say that all of
those things reduced this person's and a
que anonymity number very low so that
this note is actually quite identifiable
so if we're left with looking at all
these identifiers why don't we just take
them out all right so here's the note
now I would argue now that this note is
pretty much useless we've taken out all
the meaning and we're left with a bunch
of X's in here and there's no meaning in
the note I think this is the part work
it's really cool so wouldn't it be cool
really if we use the power of all the
information that company like Google has
at its fingertips to in real time think
about what is the age distribution in
small town Illinois is it safe to have
an 85 year old called out here do we
have to change that what about the fact
that he was ahead of son killed in an
accident or that he's an amputee Google
can check to see was that in a public
record somewhere was there a newspaper
article about it was it is there a
publicly available obituary that says
this what about the fact that he has a
huge family is that a common thing in
central Illinois do we need to do we
need to change that as well and in real
time you could take this note actually
and turn it into something that does
some of this obscuring by changing the
names maybe you could change the age a
little bit but if you change the age you
want to do it in a way that maintains
the information in the note there's an
amazing array of different things that
we could consider if you think about the
power of all the other reference data
that lives underneath the hood so the
identification is a huge problem for
research because we need so much data to
study rare for not rare phenomena like
the time that Michael talked about
looking for patients going to the ICU
you need we needed a you know ninety
thousand patients to pick up even the
smallest amount of signal so I
Deeley you would do this for many
hospitals and you would require you to
collaborate and to share data and to do
that you're going to have to standardize
the data while d identifying it and
satisfying all the different privacy
boards that you're not going to do
anything that compromises the patient's
privacy so that's why we're here today
and that's why we're so excited we're
really looking forward to this
collaboration because we're going to
understand how to use and study
sensitive data at large scale there's a
lot we have to do and there's a lot
we're going to have to do to get this
done we're going to have to figure out
how this the identification process
makes research more difficult what is
the what is the spectrum of as UD
identify things does it make research
harder to do when is HIPAA not enough I
showed you that note before and I argue
that we removed all the hit by
identifiers but you would say HIPAA is
not enough there we need to consider the
other ways you can identify people so
can these new approaches maintain
privacy while preserving the research
value of the information and finally
what tools can privacy boards used to
protect patients right now whenever our
our IRB has a tough question they turn
to Michael in me and say is this is good
enough and and I would think there's a
better set of tools that privacy boards
can start to use to standardize how we
think about privacy protection for
patients so we really think that better
d identification and better analytics
tools is going to speed up healthcare
discoveries and is really going to help
improve patient outcomes by letting us
study these enormous large sets of data
so that's why we're very excited here's
some of the groups that have helped make
this possible University of Chicago and
if we have time hopefully for Scott
Michael myself we can answer some
questions thank you
[Music]
you